♪ ♪ ♪
- Chez les Saintellemy,
la musique fait partie
de la famille.
♪ ♪ ♪
Le papa affectionne
particulièrement les sonorités
d'Haïti, où il est né.
FRANTZ SAINTELLEMY, chancelier
et président du Conseil, UdeM
- Ce style de musique représente
la misère de la diaspora
haïtienne. Elle a quitté Haïti
avec deux valises : une valise
pour res valise
pour retourner.
- La mère du chancelier a quitté
Haïti avec ses six enfants,
qu'elle a élevés seule. Frantz
avait 8 ans quand il est arrivé
au Québec. Grandir dans
une famille nombreuse a forgé
le caractère de l'ingénieur,
qui a aussi sept demi-frères
et soeurs.
- Une grande famille, tu sais,
il faut que tu négocies,
tu peux pas tout avoir.
Alors, çment aidé à,
un, faire des choix rapidement
et, deux, à savoir négocier
et tenir mon bout.
Alors, on joue dans le sens
de l'aiguille d'une montre.
- Maintenant père de trois
enfants, le chancelier souhaite
ulquer les valeurs
reçues en héritage : le goût
du travail, de l'entraide,
de la victoire.
- Ah, c'est compétitif.
- C'est clair, on joue
pour gagner.
- Veuillez accueillir
chaleures panélistes.
(applaudissements)
- Frantz Saintellemy est
une espèce rare. Chercheur
passionné d'intellé d'intellé de
artificielle, c'est aussi
un entrepreneur qui sait faire
multiplier les revenus.
- Je suis un curieux de nature.
es choses compliquées,
complexes, donc j'aime résoudre
des problèmes complexes. Donc,
ça prend ça aussi, ça prend
une certaine attitude kamikaze.
Je suis très tenace.
Je n'ai pas peur d'échouer,
d'essayer des choses qui...
puis de recommence
Leddartech est né justement
de la recherche. On est
une "spin-off" de l'inno.
- En 2017, il prend les rênes de
LeddarTech, une enssue
de l'Institut national d'optique
de Québec, qui développe des
micropuces et des capteurs
visant à rendre les automobiles
autonome: réduire: réduire: réde
les accidents mortels,
presque toujours provoqués
par des erreurs humaines.
- Si je peux vous équiper,
re cabine de véhicule,
de dispositifs qui vous
permettent d'avoir une vision
périphérique 360, comprenez quet
le nombre d'accidents bénins.
- Depuis quatre ans, le nombre
d'employés de Leddartech estpas,
des ingénieurs surtout.
Et le chiffre d'affaires a
grimpé de 100 millions, à près
d'un milliard de dollars.
(propos indistincts)
VICKIE JOSEPH
- Il est parti d'H
des gens qui n'avaient rien,
alors ils devaient apprendre
à survivre dans un pays où ils
arrivent, ils ne connaissaient
pas le français ni l'anglais.
Je dirais que c'est une question
de bataille, de résilience
quotidienne pour survivre
à ses besoins. Donc, pour m
je pense que son entrepreneuriat
est venu de là.
- L'ingénieur encourage sa femme
à se lancer en affaire, d'abord
en design de mode,
la production de cosmétiques.
Ensemble, ils ont fondé,
dans le quartier Saint-Michel,
un incubateur d'en
qui aide des immigrants
à devenir entrepreneurs.
- Comment ça va?
Et encore, on le v
aujourd'hui, dans les nouvelles,
quand il y a quelque chose qui
est relié à la violence dans
les quartiers comme Saint-Michel
et Montréal-Nord, ça prend
une démesure. Donc, et pas
pour banaliser ce qui se passe,
la violence chez les jeunes,
mais on voulait changer
la rhétorique de l'idée
de gangs de rue à un groupe
de développement économique.
Ça, c'est un détecteur
environnemental à un laser.
- Le chercheur est devenu riche
en vendant sa première
entreprise, qu'il dirigeait
en Allemagne.
- Ici, on est vraiment dans
l'espace 3737. C'e
y a des activités de formation.
- En 2012, il a investi pour
rénover une usine
désaffectée, au 3737, boulevard
Crémazie Est, à Montréal.
- Dans le secteur
technologies, tellement de gens
faisaient beaucoup d'argent,
mais ilsgent
pour s'acheter des yachts, des
grosses voitures, des grosses
maisons. Mais au-delà de ça,au-,
au-delà du gros bateau,
qu'est-ce qui se passe?
Je me suis dit : "Je peux
peut-être utiliser mon argent
à meilleur escient,
donc à investir dans
des infrastructures qui vont
peut-être être des tremplins
pour d'autres."
- Depuis sa création il y a
neuf ans, l'incubateur a aidé
plus de 1000 entrepreneurs.
- Si je regarde mon père, il a
toujours redonné à son prochain
avec zéro, avec rien. Bien,c'esc
j'aimerais pouvoir léguer ça,
pouvoir partager mon expérience,
enrichir les autres. C'est un
bien-être qui est inexplicable,
ça n'a pas de prix.
- Pour le nouveau
ce qui n'a pas de prix, c'est la
gratitude de jeunes qui osent
l'interpeller pour le remercier,
quand on vient de Montréal-Nord,
on a les stigmates de notre code
postal. Donc, on a peur de dire
qu'on vient de Montréal-Nord.Ets
peur de dire que vous avez vécu
à Montréal-Nord, à Saint-Michel,
ça nous donne espoir. Pour moi,
ça, c'est probablement le plusb.
(applaudissements)
- Le chancelier,monsieur Frantz.
- Pour la première fois
dans l'histoire du Québec,
une personne noire
la collation des grades
d'étudiants universitaires.
- C'est
Je m'apprête à remettre
des diplômes à des doctorants.
Et pour moi, ça représente
l'avenir, l'espoir.
Ça veut dire beaucoup de choses.
Chers diplômés de l'Université
de Montréal, votre oeuvre
commence.
On a gagné!
VIKTOR, fils de Frantz
Saintellemy
- Bien, on a c'est un test
de la personne que tu admires.
J'ai fait mon père.
Je suis fier de lui.
(applaud